I'm on board the Sapphire a shrimp boat
fishing the German North Sea coast
Yente stance heads out to sea almost
every day from the port of Cuxhaven he
catches shrimp and other marine animals
but a lot of trash ends up in his nets
as well
I'm sorry Lucas has motorhome we've
caught all sorts of things he says car
hoods bikes radiators but most of the
trash we catch is small stuff plastic
plants beer cans reprobates we've netted
hard hats as well it's that kind of
stuff
the world's oceans are turning into a
giant trash dump researchers estimate
that 150 million tons of rubbish is
drifting through the seas and most of
that is plastic the North Sea is no
exception
there's nothing here like the Great
Pacific or Great North Atlantic Garbage
Patch but there's still plenty of trash
in the water yen Stuntz has joined the
fishing for litter initiative it's a
voluntary program fishermen like yen's
collect the trash that ends up in their
nets and dispose of it properly on land
you have to start somewhere says yen's
for professional fishermen like him the
growing problem of garbage in the seas
is a real threat to their livelihood
the next game and then things will get
really bad if we don't do something
about it he explains and then we'll have
a problem we can't solve anymore
once the ecosystem is disrupted it can
fall apart that's just how it is
and that's going to hit what's living on
the sea when he heads back to port he
knows he'll be able to get rid of any
Trash he fishes out of the sea at no
cost to him but I'm surprised that Yin's
has brought back so little garbage it's
often a lot more he says it depends on
the fishing ground casters bits of
plastic sheeting he says some loser has
thrown in old net in there it's not
something he caught between 70 and 80
German fishermen have joined the fishing
for litter initiative it's not clear to
me just how much trash they dragged out
of the sea
not until I take a trip to the town of
Yahveh close to the coast
when the dumpsters are full they're
emptied at this recycling yard
but before the waste is disposed of it's
checked by a team of environmentalists
and researchers they pick through the
pile of trash carefully they want to
find out exactly where all this plastic
comes from Neal's movement from the
German environmental group Nabu explains
forget Sun Sun Visor it's about
individual objects he says like this
classic plastic bottle or container on
the one hand we can draw conclusions
about where these individual objects
come from and moving on from there we
can target the people we need to talk to
for example we could go to some branch
of business and ask them why they're
losing so much of this stuff and what
they can do to reverse that plastic
bottles and bags rope and nets a large
part of the trash comes from shipping
the North Sea is one of the busiest
waterways of the world and some cruise
dumped their waste overboard because
it's the quickest and easiest and least
visible way he says well they think it
is saves money so it's tempting isn't
victory in
researchers believe that there's more
than half a million cubic meters of
trash at the bottom of the North Sea
alone and plastic can last up to 500
years instead of rotting it breaks down
into smaller and smaller pieces the glue
stick of highest achieving health millet
from Germany's North Sea coast National
Park explains that animals consume this
plastic it can kill them the micro
plastic particles end up in animal
tissue and enters the food chain but
larger pieces of plastic kill as well
the North Sea and its coasts are unique
natural habitats
the tidal valency is home to 10,000
animal and plant species but this
habitat is under threat from waste
products which are simply dumped in the
sea
I want to find out more about the
effects the garbage has on the
environment so I'm meeting Neil scusa
from Keele University within the
framework of an international research
project he and his team study formers on
a regular basis full mursar bird species
which finds its food in the sea Neil
says that full MERS often eat large
amounts of plastic particles as do many
other marine animals myself as plastic
and in my line of attack we know that
plastic breaks down into smaller and
smaller pieces he says and we find it in
other marine organisms like fish or
smaller animals like shellfish and so on
so that means that in principle we can
prove the presence of plastic and small
animals and all the way up the marine
food chain to the large marine mammals
we found it in whales as well scientists
have dissected more than 1,500 dead
formers more than ninety percent of them
had plastic in their stomachs lucky for
felicity Neil says the most common cause
of death is starvation that's something
that happens under normal circumstances
but sometimes it's the case that there
is so much plastic in their stomachs
that it kills them because the bird is
no longer able to eat any other food but
that's not the case with this bird but
that doesn't mean the animal is free of
plastic
the guts of the bird contain a number of
small objects which they identify as
pellets of recycled plastic into the
recycling TelePresence indeed o king the
specimen note Neil says objects like
this were once parts of a product which
ended up in the sea after being dumped
and plastic like this can increase the
concentration of toxic substances in the
sea
that's a danger to humans who can end up
consuming those substances in the fish
they eat
I head off for Borkum it's an island off
the North Sea coast and popular with
holidaymakers the beaches look clean but
Borkum has the same problem as other
islands and coastal areas rubbish gets
washed up on the beach but the people
here aren't doing something about it the
volunteers are told what to do with the
different kinds of rubbish they are
likely to find every autumn people
around the world head to the beaches to
remove the trash groups from about 100
countries are involved
and here in Bochum it's no different
there are plenty of people willing to
clean up their stretch of coast a lot of
people feel driven to act against the
flood of garbage on the beaches
themselves politicians aren't getting
the job done the European Union plans to
require Member States to drastically
reduce marine waste by 2020 but many
people doubt things will change and as
long as that's the case
trash keeps ending up in the sea from
the local nature conservation group says
that angers him especially when the
autumn storms dumped more trash on a
beach they've just cleaned and then they
have to start all over again an
estimated 20,000 tons of garbage ends up
in the North Sea every year in just one
afternoon the volunteers on Borkum
collect 40 sacks of trash it's always
like this says this woman and she
reckons there's a lot more buried under
the sand a lot more gets exposed after
storm surges and most of it is plastic
hence our place looks after
environmental issues on the island
there's a lot of small threats he says
they're the remnants of fishing nets
they're not really that obvious
especially in the mass of things that
get washed up like seaweed and feathers
it's pretty hidden but you can hardly
take a step without finding bits of
plastic
the seas are full of trash that's a
threat to the environment and to us as
well it's becoming clear to me that
although the sea is beautiful to look at
it's a time bomb waiting to explode